bang-bang what's up lunch money time
well while she's trying to get rest rest
I was trying to get lunch money right
it's Monday I'm pumped for what polina
Papa Leone oh is here with me yeah in
her red what is it lady in red isn't
that a song yes but I think it supposed
to be a red dress not a red blazer
blazer
don't forget much money's now boss my
block fie bang bang get money get paid
go and use one of their three products
you can buy and sell crypto you can
deposit crypto and take out a u.s.
dollar loan so that you get liquidity
without selling your crypto or you can
deposit crypto or a stable coin and earn
of 28.6% a py and an interest-bearing
account it's a no-brainer
it has risk go do your research but go
sign up wat phou kham slash lunch money
alright what's up how was your weekend
great awesome let's go on stock market
just took a shower so it kind of looks
like my hair sweaty but it's not sweaty
I just like Turkish shower that's why
okay um so hedge fund billionaire Leon
Cooperman said he thinks the market is
overvalued and that is overlooking a
number of things I think you wrote about
this kind of in your newsletter this
morning do you wanna talk about it no
but I will talk about it yes you did I
mean look at the end of the day is it
overvalued you can look at valuation in
a couple different ways you can value it
based on the company's fundamentals you
can value it on the market right it's
particularly drawing attention to the
federal deficit oh yeah I mean look
here's my favorite stat for the last six
fiscal years in a row the government has
collected more income tax revenue each
year so six years ago was the highest
ever then the year after that was the
highest ever highest ever highs all the
way up the last six years it's been an
increasing hitting new all-time highs
record levels of revenue for the
government yet at the same time the
deficit on an annual basis has grown
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and bigger well
how does that happen the deficit is
growing he says and rate well in excess
of the growth of the economy well
there's two rates to pay attention to so
for those that don't know the deficit
right is a big fancy finance word for
simply how much more money do we spend
to get close then we actually make so
think of it as a business if a business
brought in a hundred dollars of revenue
but it spent two hundred dollars it
would have a hundred dollar deficit that
it ran for that year the government ends
up bringing in hundreds of billions of
dollars or trillions of dollars
depending on the year and how you count
but they have a deficit they spend more
than they make but the problem is that
that gap between what they spend or what
they make and what they spend is getting
bigger and bigger and bigger each year
and so on a net basis each year as the
deficit gets larger and larger that
contributes more deficit to the national
debt so today the national debt is over
26 trillion dollars the US has 26
trillion dollars of assets spent it on
well that's a great question every year
the US government spends 40% of the
money on people over the age of 65 the
old people take 40% of the government
spending I'm okay with old people taking
money by the end of 2030 right by the
end of the 2020 decade 50% of the US
government spending is projected to go
to people over the age of 65 why because
we live in a society where people are
not given the tools to build safety
security and savings for themselves in
savings guys we get to a world where
when you hit the age of 65 you are
dependent on the US government
supporting you know that 40 percent of
spending goes to literally 40 percent of
our spending in the u.s. goes to at a
government level some people over the
age of 65 we could drastically reduce
that if we gave people the tools so that
they could have a better better savings
speaking of tools Coursera
the online learning platform that offers
classes
taught by instructors at top
universities like Stanford and Johns
Hopkins has raised an additional 130
million dollars and it is valued at
approximately 2.5 billion okay is this
does this have anything to do with all
these Ivy League's and whatever and
people ditching traditional education in
favor of online schooling I think people
just generally want to learn they got
time on their hands they're sitting at
home they're saying why don't I learn
something that's cool
yeah the pandemic has given a huge boost
of virtual learning providers yeah but
do you think something like Coursera
could ever replace traditional
universities
yeah probably well I mean I don't know
if it's Coursera specifically a lamb to
school like but absolutely I think
higher education is got a target on its
back I don't know what the time period
that's the hardest part with predictions
is like what's gonna happen in how long
the front half of the prediction of is
higher education increasing in
popularity and value or decreasing it's
absolutely decreasing will it go to zero
so there will be no colleges that feels
like a pretty hard thing to call do they
look very different in the future and
they're like all online you don't
physically go to a place I really do
think though that lets say my education
at the University of Georgia maybe I
could have replaced 80% of it of the
actual content via virtual learning but
the social component is largely why
people choose to go to universities
correct yes but it but that's kind of
the point is kind of get replaced by
something else it's just not the same
why isn't it cuz you're not living with
your peers you're not learning together
you're not getting together to study why
can't you still do that virtually so one
thing would say rather than you go all
to the same campus and go to the same
school why don't you just go to
apartment building or like a dorm room
that's in your town and then all of a
sudden you guys are all actually taking
classes at different schools it's not as
immersive why not because you have to go
out of your way to do it in college it
just naturally happens you're naturally
sharing ideas with each other in the
Dyne
or whatever it just it's not as natural
to do it like that
yeah what I'm saying is basically
there's a very strong argument
I actually think somebody should do this
this would be a great business they
should create a college campus and
doesn't have to be like an actual like
big sprawling campus it could just be
take over a mall and create that the
college campus there but you have no
classrooms and what I mean by that is no
no you create a college ok campus like
environment but you tell everyone we're
gonna do everything for you other than
the education the education you're gonna
get online so you can take that in your
dorm room or we've got like little
offices that you can break out into or
whatever but I'll take your online
courses but you can live here you can
get all the experience on the social
thing is a college yes but the unit
economics are way better as a business
because you're not having to pay tenured
teachers you don't have to get into all
they have virtual but then half social
in terms of like you go to this so the
lor the learning is virtual like so
here's a perfect example if you take a
very simple subject let's take political
science right and how many good
political science professors are there
in the country I don't know let's just
say easy number is there's a couple
hundred right there's probably three
that are the best right why are we
educating our country and our citizens
with the 398 best versus just the best 3
why don't we take the best 3 to have
them teach everybody political so
because you could technically teach on
an unlimited number of students
virtually but at the same time you don't
get the individualized attention you
would if you were in their 30 person
class you could take the 300 98th best
professor and turn them into an
assistant for the class ok I just think
it's gonna look very different somebody
like a Coursera somebody like a lamb to
school like that online education is a
very big trend I think it's only gonna
accelerate
that's what yep you agree yes nice we
agreed on something on a Monday perfect
ok
no singing what's up Mars the UAE the
Emirates successfully launched a Mars
probe making history
for the Arab world so basically they're
very confused by the UAE has
successfully launched is its Mars probe
named Hope which you know they have
liftoff they're going it launched from
the Japanese Space Center on Sunday and
it's going to Mars I feel like nobody
heard about this and then all of a
sudden yesterday people are like oh
there's a Mars probe
everyone's like wait what like where did
this come from and it's really not that
big of a thing like 200 million dollar
project yeah it's really not that
expensive to be honest and it's
scheduled to reach Mars is orbit in
February of 2021 and it will spend one
Mars year equivalent to 687 days on
earth studying and gathering data on the
red planet's atmosphere so does it is it
actually gonna land on Mars I don't
think that it's going to so is just
gonna circle around I'm not really sure
it's a probe it's not a rover right
which i think means that it's basically
going to be in the Mars atmosphere and
kind of circulate around but it's not
actually going to land yeah I guess it's
just gonna gather data on the atmosphere
of Mars still pretty cool okay Mars is
pretty far away if they're launching it
now in July it's not gonna get there
till February it kind of feels like a
long time it is a long time NASA the
Mars rover tweeted to the whole
permission congratulations on your
launch I wish you a successful journey
and look forward to the soul what the
hell when we are both exploring Mars I
really don't like it when inanimate
objects tweet at each other I don't get
well Polina that's because they have
humans running their Twitter but I don't
like it just say you're a human say you
know the humans at NASA wish you I don't
like that look at the end of the day I
hope every single country sends as much
stuff into space as possible let's go
learn as much as we can
awesome big fan I like that the
countries are supporting each other even
tournament objects all right what's
going on with uh with mr. musk and his
neural link okay what the hell
Elon Musk claims his neural link
if you remember neuro-link is his like
brain computer interfaces company uh
that his neural link chip will allow you
to stream music directly to your brain
what does that mean the four most
important technologies in my mind right
now are Bitcoin which is gonna disrupt
money and change the way that everyone
interacts with and sends value to space
which is the next frontier and we have
to become a multi planetary species
three is longevity seventy seven year
age expectancy in the world today we can
drastically increase that my guess is
that in my lifetime somebody will be
born that will live to 150 years old
probably uh yeah maybe your grandmother
but she's probably not gonna be and the
fourth one is the augmentation of the
human brain
meaning that computers are incredibly
intelligent our brains are essentially
just computers can we use artificial
augmentation to make ourselves smarter
think faster more accurately etc
neuro-link is one of those and the whole
idea right now is rather than it be
implantable like actually put something
in the brain they're starting with like
a thing that kind of goes behind your
ear almost and if you really think about
it there's not a huge difference between
putting something in your ear or over
your ear and right behind your ear right
like there's still some of the bone
structures and stuff like that because
basically it's the impulses I don't know
the exact science so I don't want to go
to the detailer because somebody will
call me out for being an idiot but I do
know that all around this area is
there's multiple ways to get sound waves
right essentially what music is is just
into your brain have your brain compute
what's going on so you can click hear it
that's a while yeah major science right
and so what ends up occurring is if
neural link can basically be that close
and can figure out how to do it of
course this little device will be able
to send it what's crazier to me is the
batteries they're gonna be needed for
this type of stuff right like that the
innovation in battery technology is
going to be nuts because I got a plug in
my phone everyday I got a plug on my
watch every 36 hours
well happens when you can put something
whether it's on your skin or actually
implanted in your brain and it lasts for
you know two decades let's say it's
gonna be incredible so I was always of
opinion that like oh no you know what
are we gonna become like cyborgs when
you put a chip in your brain buh-buh-bah
and like I was just always kind of
against it cuz I hadn't actually thought
about how it can really help people and
then I interviewed a man who is
quadriplegic and he implanted a chip in
his brain to help with dexterity and
exterior yeah he can't move anything it
would be dexterity with his hand because
he can't like the thing basically the
the computer sends signals where it can
move your fingers and you can grab a
block for example the problem is that
you know the computer the technology is
a little bit further behind but the data
that they they've been able to gather
from his brain and everything they've
been doing this with him I think for now
20 years or 15 years so I think for
things like that it's it's really
amazing all these articles all this
stuff talks about music and like things
that aren't really essential sooner
related that schools do want to click on
it but if you have concerns or you're
paralyzed or things like that I think it
could be super interesting well I think
that's where they're gonna get the first
people to actually embed them right is
to say hack it stream music to your
brain yeah there's some like you know
tech nerds that don't know it but
they're not gonna get the mass consumer
to do it if they instead say hey we can
help you actually fix medical situations
that then that's gonna be better the
other thing that's really interesting is
a lot of people forget that because your
brain is a computer like you if you map
the entire brain and then you're able to
tell okay we know that when we send
electrical signals to this part of the
brain we can actually make you move your
arm or we can make you move your leg or
whatever like that would be a massive
inflection point in human history to be
able to artificially kind of manipulate
the brain to do things that it
previously isn't doing the problem is
that we don't understand the brain super
well right it's probably one of the
most complex organisms in the world
there's so many different elements to it
between sections of the brain all the
electrical connections all kind of stuff
so I think things like neural link and
this promise of like hey you're gonna be
a superhuman it's actually gonna drive a
ton of scientific research and
understanding of the human brain which
overall I think it's a good thing too
it's kind of like we we just got a
Roomba and this little robot is going
around the apartment studying it and
mapping it I hate this he he like
assaulted it the other day it got it got
no it got up in the cords here and you
just took it and threw it on the other
side all of a sudden
excuse me I didn't okay that was it was
it was aggressive in the room but robot
couldn't reason with it so I had to use
physical it was terrifying to move it
all right speaking of human augmentation
and creating superhumans what's up with
GPT three okay this is super interesting
I you told me about it the other day and
now I just started reading about it but
apparently so open AI that is also
backed by Elon Musk correct kind of kind
of so it is financially back so open AI
is a organization it started out as a
nonprofit they now have a for-profit arm
that they're setting up and what they
are doing is they are essentially trying
to figure out the ethical implementation
of artificial intelligence and
specifically what they're looking for is
they're trying to come up with general
artificial intelligence so the quick
breakdown here is when you hear the word
artificial intelligence people who are
very deeply entrenched in the industry
will tell you there is no such thing as
artificial intelligence there's usually
machine learning where we feed a
computer a bunch of data we train it and
then it can do certain very specific
types of but the idea of artificial
intelligence does not really exist and
so open AI is basically start out as a
non-profit it was founded by Elon Musk
Sam Altman a whole bunch of people they
put a bunch of money behind it they've
now created a for-profit arm they
recently did a deal with Microsoft like
a billion dollars but they're gonna get
financial support and the whole idea is
like let's create artificial
intelligence general AI specifically
that's implemented in a very ethical way
or it's a lot of concerns around
artificial intelligence and how it can
be used for nefarious purposes long
story short is AI doesn't exist yet
today in kind of form that people think
it does a lot of is just machine
learning and other types of technologies
open AI previously last year launched g
bt g to me GPT to which is generative
pre-training transformer to which is
their second version it was pretty cool
you could type things in and it would
give you information back they've now
released GPT 3 so generative
pre-training transformer 3 and it is
mind blow it says it's the most powerful
language model ever built can I just
tell you what it's been used for so far
yes it says its language capabilities
are breathtaking when properly primed by
a human it can write creative fiction
generate function and code compose
thoughtful business memos and I saw on
Twitter this guy used it as a therapist
which is very interesting yeah what
people are basically doing is they're
testing its limitations so you can
request access through open AI and you
can test like what can this thing
actually do and so a lot of people have
done like you just mentioned there's a
guy who took his investment memo so it's
basically just a rundown on a company he
cut off half of it he fed the first half
to the Machine and said finish my
investment memo for me and the Machine
kicked out like a pretty compelling
second parts of the memo and when you
read both of them like it's kind of hard
to tell which one did the Machine write
which one to the human right there's
other people who are describing in plain
English they're saying create a that has
this button that says this this whatever
there's writing in plain plain English
the design of a technology product and
then this GPT 3 is able to basically
compute what is said in English and turn
it into code and then present it you can
start playing with the product within
seconds and so ultimately like there's
this isn't kind of a finished product
but I do think that it's signals like
there's going to be a massive
augmentation of human intelligence where
the machines are gonna be way smarter
than us they're gonna
drastically increase our ability to do
certain things and this is a prime
example of you know as people kind of
play with it they're like whoa the
world's gonna look way different in the
future the therapy thing is a little
what double-edged sword because to be a
therapist you need to be licensed and
you need to go through all these things
you see do you can use it as therapy why
don't they get away no fact anyway it's
just not everybody can be giving like
advice for this type of stuff and then
yet here is the AI and this guy loved it
but see that this is the world that
we've been tricked the only reason why
there's licensing it's not because you
need a license to give therapy it's
because what happens is we live in a
legal society where everyone loves to
sue each other and the license is there
to protect L somebody from being sued
and also like you know it can lead to
you being prescribed certain things
depending on what I think you have it's
just it's tough of course the AI is
gonna prescribe it's gonna completely
remove anything that's diagnostic in
nature is gonna get removed and a
computers can be able to do it better
it's already happening in hospitals
where they can look at MRI scans I think
it is and the MRI scan that's read by a
computer is more accurate than when you
put doctors on I think it's a it's not a
cat scan maybe or an x-ray um I think
it's great what a radiologist
x-rays okay yeah I think that's it okay
KFC is working with the Russian 3d
bioprinting firm to try and make a lab
produced chicken nuggets what do you
think I don't know what do you think
they are printing chicken meat remember
chicken balls
yeah but 3d bioprinting yeah by the way
who's gonna trust the Russian 3d
bioprinting solutions KFC is thing
that's gonna print chicken meat using
chicken cells and plant material I mean
maybe look at here's my only concern
with all this stuff is obviously there's
beyond me there's impossible in Foods
right as out it is there's you know this
3d by Sony bioprinting whatever we just
don't know the long-term impact of
consuming this stuff so it's kind of
like cigarettes I get the time everyone
thought they were all right
you admit that kills people I don't know
we'll see what happens yeah I want to
know if I'm meeting the real animal or
not so weird you're such a far before
omnivore omnivore was that way don't
look at my joke listen II wasn't
carnivore isn't carnivore just meat and
omnivores you can eat plants and animals
I don't know that's science stuff I just
stick to the tech side
by the way breaking news Nicki Minaj
expecting your first baby no problem
that's what that's what you get you get
some bonus content here at a lunch money
time just broke 18 minutes ago on
Twitter she and her husband Kenneth
petty are expecting their first child
together
yes Nicki Minaj's English child me where
a girl will be poppin yeah he'll be a
little savage alright that's it for
lunch money
well while she's trying to get rich for
us so it's just trying to get her lunch
money right see you guys later
bang-bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money's now sponsored
by block five so go check them out
there's a link in the description that
you can click on I'm an investor a user
and a huge fan what you're a bigger fan
of block fire than you are of me block
wise my second favorite thing in the
world behind polina
they've got 3 products they can give you
a US dollar loan you can earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but eight point six percent
it's pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks that block by subscribe to our
channel like the video annoy plan in the
comment and we'll see you guys tomorrow
and be kind to your friends